so there's this app that's a trivia game
called HQ I'm sure you guys have played
it everyone's talking about it actually
haven't played it yet but someone just
told me that you can win money playing
HQ I like money so I thought you know
what I'm gonna download it but I'm not
just gonna try it I'm gonna win it but
I'm not just gonna win it I'm gonna
master it but I'm not just gonna man
yeah the joke was over about a minute
ago let's go play some HQ all right so I
just downloaded HQ I'm actually pretty
nervous I really hope that this video is
just like one minute long it's my intro
and then just me mastering it
immediately this is weird if the app is
very like old school and there's just
comments non-stop Scott Scotty Skye so I
have three minutes till the game starts
and I guess I'll just take this time to
kind of prepare a little training two
plus two equals four finish this
sentence Mickey Mouse Clubhouse lists
the presidents in order George
Washington alright the game started of
seven hundred twenty thousand people
playing I can beat seven hundred twenty
thousand PD that's a show PD means
police right
I'm so upset I could have easily won let
me see Catherine Howard how am I
supposed to know this stuff Heather now
it sounds like a friend of my mom's like
even though I was frustrated I kept
playing I had hoped that I could win
this game and I played every chance I
got the only problem was that I kept
losing over and over again but then I
got an idea
I'm just gonna go around the office see
who knows HQ best and see if they want
to join my HQ team you know HQ
headquarters
no not headquarters the game HQ no
actually I'm not familiar with it do you
know what HQ is yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
trying to make a team so that we can
earn in every single job sure sure sure
that's a fantastic so do you guys like
split the $5 earnings if you win how
well thought-out is this team not at all
which of these cities was never a
capital of the Persian Empire oh I can't
pronounce any of these Nineveh Baghdad
pasar got Mariah ok skip this question
cuz I can't pronounce it which TV show
was rebooted as a sequel but with new
actors as the same characters Mack
MacGyver MacGyver which of these snacks
was founded in Finland leaning back to
around 6000 BC
tater chips chewing gum cheese sticks
cheese sticks Dave my man did I get it
no wait a second you're not Scott yeah
here actress Emma Watson studied at
witch University Harvard Brown or
Cambridge Brown you are correct sir you
know what four four four that's good
enough I think you've made the team out
we have no more questions I feel like
you're not doing this very well no but I
just I'm sick of trying to find this
team so I'm just gonna accept socials
gonna be you and Sarah no no I mean so
far yeah it's not a team my cameraman
was right I had to step up my game I had
to talk to everyone in the office and
form the ultimate HQ team that's what I
did we were confident yeah we were we
were a little too confident we were
really confident that's such a hard
question if we all get out on clearly
not gonna shoot my elbow we were doing
so well I thought we were all gonna win
until this one question
we made it to the final round
it was an easy question and so we won
but I wasn't satisfied because I wasn't
the one who won and that's what I set
out to do in this video so there was
more work to be done so I'm gonna talk
to some of the best HQ players and see
what advice they have what wait I didn't
know that is that are you the top winner
Casey Donahue I'm Casey Donahue I'm one
of the all-time winners on HQ trivia and
Zach Warren told I work at BuzzFeed I'm
one of the try guys and I'm also in HQ T
what you might not know about me is that
I am a four time HQ champion I've been
playing HQ for like two weeks now and I
had no luck do you have any advice how
do I win this game I'm not gonna lie and
pretend that I have won all by myself
you know playing with your friends you
know you only have three seconds to
Google but can you google something that
points you in the right direction the
night I want I played a little more
loose wasn't overthinking it and I think
you are in the right mindset to win the
game honestly from the richest HQ player
coming from you that's I think I'm gonna
win now I was so nervous while playing
the game that I actually forgot to talk
I just wanted to focus on the questions
and the answers that's what I did and I
answered a lot right so many actually
that I meet it to the twelfth question
it's the most stressful moment in my
life this meant so much to me I mean not
really but it did oh my god there is no
one in the office for me to share this
with $34 I managed you master mom I won
HQ but it's that unbelievable for me to
win HQ anyway lesson learned
Google helps a lot having a group of
people like you know 20 people texting
what they think the answer is really
helps but sometimes you have to trust
yourself and not trust them the game is
fun Erica proved I love it
[Music]